some of the things you missed in this
trailer point to this being the darkest
purge movie yet if you want to see what
I mean then stick around to the end of
this video one of the things that's
always left me wanting more with the
purge movies is that they're so focused
on murder I mean come on the rules of
the purge state that all crime will be
legal for 12 hours
I mean sure there's that girl who wants
to steal a candy bar whatever an
election year but where are all the
vandals trespassers kidnappers drug
dealers and other criminals that don't
involve murder in my mind that's the fun
stuff I'd be wanting to do on purge
night it looks like this prequel may
help explain why we don't see a lot of
that stuff in subsequent purges one of
the first images we see is this chick on
a swing in an industrial looking
building if you pause you'll see she's
in a high voltage area and a lot of the
other images we see from the beginning
of this first purge just seem to be
young people blowing things up doing
shenanigans and even holding crazy
parties in the street with no
consequences none of them seemed to have
very malicious intent so the President
and this woman who came up with the idea
for the purge are monitoring these
activities and the president seems
disappointed that there aren't more
people getting violent parties you
predicted a much higher level of
participation because remember one of
the main conspiracies from the three
existing purge films is that the purge
is just a way for the government to
clean up their streets by killing off
the poor who are the ones who are most
vulnerable during the purge in order to
go through with this agenda the
president tampers with the experiment by
artificially introducing murder into the
equation your civic soldiers into the
island disguised as citizens this
president is corrupt and he's using the
Staten Island purge experiment as a
front for the American public to
convince them that the purge is helping
the country so he can get what he wants
the new founding fathers of America or
the nffa are the political party that
supports the purge and this president is
most likely their first member to gain
power
he even replaces the United States coat
of arms flag in the Oval Office
with this flag which looks to have the
last two letters from the acronym Anitha
along with the preliminary version of
the logo he also wears an nffa pin right
next to his American flag there's
evidence that he's going to be
manipulating the purge in more ways than
one
since this purge is just an experiment
its outcome can greatly affect the
possibility of future countrywide purges
taking place and since this one just
takes place in an isolated environment
on Staten Island the president is gonna
want to be able to control the
perception of the experiment by the rest
of the American people throughout the
trailer there are these broadcasts by a
channel named CNB which is most likely a
play on CNN which stands for a cable
news network so I imagine CNB stands for
a cable news broadcast or something
throughout the trailer they're the only
ones covering the events of the purge
including live broadcasts from inside
the purge and propaganda to convince the
public that there's no political agenda
behind the controversial holiday is the
perd a political device it is a
psychological one if we want to save our
country we must release all our anger in
one night seeing as how the purge movies
have tied themselves in with the current
political movements in America I
wouldn't be surprised if CNB Network
took a page out of CNN's book and became
involved in some fake news allegations
they could even be a pawn of the nffa
used to make the American people think
what their government wants them to
think of course there's always gonna be
backlash which brings us to our main
character it seems like she's already a
rebellious voice in her community before
the announcement of the purge she's
already got this megaphone which we see
her used later at the purge protests the
protest has some interesting signage we
see more references to the current
real-life American political standing
like this not my purged sign which is a
parody of the not my president signs
held by opposers of current US President
Donald Trump there's also a sign that
says we are not gun lobby at nffa murder
and if you skim through frame by frame
you can see the sign in the background
that says the 28th is a ha which most
likely says the 28th is a hate crime so
what does this mean currently the US
Constitution has 27 amendments or 27
rules in this movie it looks like the
purge will become the 28th amendment so
there's a little bit of insight on how
the purge came to be recognized by the
US government and then saying that it's
a hate crime means that it's a violent
act motivated by prejudice in this case
and act created to wipe out the
lower-class
sending soldiers in to tamper with the
experiment may not be the only
suspicious activity the president is up
to them at the location where the
president
and dr. up Dale are interviewed by CNB
you can pause and read the sign in the
background if you combine this shot with
another screenshot where the sign is
present you can put the two together to
read wants to make $5,000 participate in
the Staten Island experiment no
experience no background checks no drug
testing something something an FFA I
have two theories about what this job
could entail this could be a call for
more mercenaries to send into the purge
and incite violence in this trailer we
see more traditional looking soldiers
and these creepy looking fighters who
also seem to be part of organized units
it's possible that the president is
sending two opposing groups into the
purge on orders to kill each other was
no knowledge that the other has been
hired this would naturally cause them to
get into a huge battle to help prove the
MFA's point that violence has been pent
up inside of everybody and needs to be
released my other theory is that the
nffa is targeting the poor and trying to
send homeless people from across the
country into the Staten Island purge
they would probably be the most
desperate unlikely to risk their lives
for such a small sum of money and it
would help the suppose at agenda of the
nffa trying to clean up the streets
remember in the other movies the nffa
and their rich supporters almost take
the killing of homeless people as a
religious ritual in election year they
even hold the ceremonious killings in
the church this new trailer suggests
even more of a religious side to the
purge than we've seen before tonight
we'll see the good and evil in every one
there's actually a ton of evidence in
the trailer to show that the purge is
somehow tied into Satanism so I'm gonna
run through and point out what I noticed
feel free to leave your own ideas in the
comments in other perjury movies we've
seen creepy masks of American symbols
like Uncle Sam and the Statue of Liberty
in this movie the masks look more
demonic there is a pentagram on the wall
right here one of the signs in the
protest accuses the government of
turning Staten Island into Satan Island
and then on the other side of that shot
the man holds a sign reading rise above
which seems to be a counterbalance to
the Satan Island sign when the
experiment begins there's a lot of
people hiding out in what appears to be
a church pause right here there's a
battle that goes on in the intersection
of Genesee and
Ivy I look it up in Google Maps and
that's the location of a baptist church
if you pause right here there's yet
another church in the background but at
the beginning of this video when I said
there's something really dark going on
in the trailer I wasn't even talking
about the Satanism it looks like there's
a group out there actually targeting
kids there's a scene of these women
using a child's furniture to barricade a
room and there's a scene where a teddy
bear is wired with explosives if you
look closely you'll notice that there's
a whole alley full of children's toys
read up to explosives including baby
dolls teddy bears and more it looks like
maybe the rules seen in the other three
movies that bans class for explosives
hasn't been introduced yet and this may
be the reason that the rule is added
this next one could be a really cool
reference or just a coincidence let me
know your thoughts on it this rich guy
has a pool table with a few balls left
out if the pool cue represents a slash
then the ball spell out 3/12 ten twelve
plus ten is twenty two and three slash
twenty two is March 22nd the day that
the purge ends each year it could mean
that this guy wants to see the purge end
once and for all and my last thing you
missed from this trailer is actually
just the title cards scattered
throughout at first they appear to be
bandages but as the video goes on they
become more and more stained with blood
until the end of the trailer where they
have now become the stripes of the
American flag suggesting that the
identity of the country is now stained
with blood this has been a crazy video
week I already released two things you
missed earlier in the week on cargo in a
quiet place so make sure you check those
out if you haven't already and make sure
you're prepared for the purge this year
by subscribing to seize these worlds for
new Horrors every week ring that death
bell for notifications and I will see
you in the next one assuming we both
survive